[Musique]
est-ce que retenir son souffle permet de
détecter le corps en a deux
cette croyance qui circule abondamment
sur le web propose de faire un test à
faire soi même
respirez profondément retenir son
souffle pendant 10 secondes
et si on parvient à le faire sans
tousser ou sans inconfort
ça nous indique qu'on n'a pas le corona
virus ma collègue gauche pragmatique
s'est penché sur ces publications qui
circule de plus en plus première chose à
retenir certaines personnes malades
présentent de très faibles symptômes
ça signifie que même si on passe à
travers ce test avec succès on peut
malgré tout est infecté et être
contagieux et soyons sérieux le test de
dépistage pour l'actuel coronavirus ça
ne se fait pas la maison dans son salon
mais dans une clinique spécialisée
on introduit une tige dans le nez du
patient ont fait des prélèvements on
envoie son laboratoire à des fins
d'analysé
c'est comme ça que ça se fait finalement
plusieurs de ses publications
soutiennent que les personnes atteintes
de la coop et 19 sont environ 50% de
fibrose pulmonaire quand elles se
présentent à l'hôpital
c'est pas vrai certaines personnes
atteintes de la kobe 19 peuvent
développer une pneumonie c'est une
infection pulmonaire
mais la fibrose pulmonaire c'est une
toute autre maladie vous voyez circuler
des informations du genre n'hésitez pas
à nous écrire à notre courriel celui des
décrypteurs décrypteurs pluriel à
commercer à la radio tirait canada.ca et
notre page web et notre groupe facebook
aussi allez salut